how did the movie come about was this
something that Helen and Sharon had
wanted to do and then came to you
well actually it's it's based on some
articles that Helen Fielding wrote
she brought bridget back in 2006 and
wrote a series of articles for The
Telegraph in London and working title
bought the rights to the articles and
the concept of the script came from
those and Helen initiated it and so this
story and everything is is yes with her
concept and bringing Sharon back to is
that all part of that um I think that
came a lot later
um the conversations about the script
happened very early on and I think
around two thousand seven or eight
anything they started to talk about
maybe wanting to revisit the the
franchise and and then Sharon came on
when the script started to come together
and I think mm I can't believe it's been
so much time 2014 I think because I also
noticed that Dan is that Dan Mazer is
how do you pronounce his last name was
one of the co writers and also AM
Thomson so did they come involved after
a Helen wrote the first script and then
they came in and worked on it too did
Emma do a lot of her scenes I mean was
her section was written by her the ones
were you she was writing on the fly very
much every take was different which was
really fun too well yeah I mean did she
hand you script pages and say this is
what sometimes we'd asked for him yeah
she says quite brilliant actually the
pregnancy a lot of that who was her
experience and yeah a lot of the you
know as the script expanded and the
story expanded a lot of that had to do
with Emma's contribution there Patrick
how did you get involved you're the new
kid on the block with this now I know I
have a chance to do comedy cuz you know
you did started out doing comedy and in
the mood and can't
I mean love and whatever that that bacon
movie was if you can't remember the name
of an enchanted but you know you're kind
of more known for you know drama in a
way but how did this come how did you
get involved
interest in you and and doing this we
take a look at the script I read the
script I liked it very much and then we
worked out the dates it was you know I I
enjoyed the scenes where she's in the
control booth talking to I thought those
were really funny and the pace of that
was great and then I came across Jack
and I was like oh this could be fun be
challenging
certainly in just because just kind of
stepping into this and how does it add
value will people embrace this character
you know all those things you're looking
for love but you you know you're you're
everybody's looking for love in this
movie but you're sort of you know you
don't want kids but you're the one who
becomes really you know paternal when
she it becomes pretty you know I mean
you're looking for you know you're
looking for a lot of things he's looking
for a lot of things and trying to find
the answers to those questions
yes he's more than just his website yeah
here's a guy who created a website there
right brings people together and he's
not with someone not with Sam when so he
needs to work on his own algorithm until
he meets you and then it's all good I
always wondered because there is so much
comedy and slapstick in this movie I
mean I thought the scenes with when
first Colin is carrying you to the
hospital and then you stop by and then
you both and then you're trying to get
get you in the door I mean it was like
you know kind of like old-fashioned
slapstick you know but you know
everybody says oh when you do a comedy
you have to be very serious it's just a
serious is doing drama and even more so
because you if you try to be funny it's
not going to be funny but so was this
all timed out or did you just work it
out the three of you and the and Sharon
work out how to do this
well logistically there weren't very
many ways to you know write maybe get
from point A to point B Colin liked to
joke that people might find it amusing
because on the day that they didn't it
all find for joking that in the old days
you'd roll out you know and you'd have
to stop you'd have to cut because the
film reel would roll out you have to
change the film reel but not anymore
the guys would be talking to each other
did she say cut did she but that's very
much that was a long sequence I mean did
it take a long time I mean it took us a
few days to do that yes I mean it wasn't
much in the script and then it was okay
here's what's working right and we would
build upon that and keep it try to keep
it afloat yeah what did you see to walk
back get back into Richards shoes and be
her yeah and in a lot of ways it was cuz
she's I you know I feel like I know her
she's familiar to me in the process is
of course more familiar to me
now than before but at the same time was
a new kind of experience to rediscover a
character further along in her life
experience and try to even make
decisions about how to show that she's
evolved mhm
how to choose the ways in which she
hasn't evolved well yeah it was it was a
new kind of challenge because she said
you know successful TV producer now you
know I mean she's really we've seen her
keep changing and you know she's a very
successful TV producer but I thought it
was interesting she's still living in
her same apartment mmm you know she's
probably making more money and she's
still there
yes she's bought that apartment now it
was hard thing to do in London England
she's probably so much in debt right now
that's why she's still living there but
then again that second train line that
really does exist now right outside the
window was probably helpful why do you
think people women especially identify
so much for her you know I mean you know
kiss we catch her at 43
and she's successful but she's still
yearning for love and a family but she
you know it's but she has the career is
do you think have a lot of women since
this like has open it England talked to
you about about Bridget and what she you
know why they identify with her or do
they identify with her well sure I mean
in my opinion I would say women because
we empathize with her experiences we
recognize them but I also think that
people just in general so many men come
up to me and share their stories about
why they feel like their Bridget Jones I
think you know it's her humanity I think
people I think people recognize
themselves in her anxieties and her
fears that she's not going to measure up
in the things that she hopes for and the
challenges that she faces and it's
interesting being privy to her inner
dialogue about those anxieties because
we relate to those experiences mm-hmm
we know who it is that she thinks she's
supposed to be versus the truth of who
she is it's like knowing her like we
know ourselves we know her secrets like
we know her own and I think that
everybody kind of sees themselves in
Bridget in some way I think that's why
she's sort of I don't know she holds a
lot of meaning for a lot of people right
because she triumphs in spite of or
maybe because of her imperfections and
that makes us cheer for her well I
appreciate you guys coming thanks for
having thanks for having us thank you
very thank you for coming